don't be afraid to be difficult it's
such a word that we hear a lot these
days oh she's being difficult it's not a
bad thing you're just taking care of you
hi i'm simone ashley and this is my
glamour unfiltered
i guess i didn't really watch period
dramas much because i felt like i
couldn't relate to them
and i always thought it was because i
just wasn't interested in them but i i
love period dramas um
i love getting lost in that those
romantic stories
of like pride and prejudice everyone
should be seen i think we can all relate
to each other in some way
feelings are feelings and we all have
them um so it's great to portray
characters where people can relate to
how they look and relate to a human
feeling as well i think kate's really
mature and i've learned a lot from her
in that sense i think maybe i can
sometimes be a bit of a people pleaser
sometimes you can just call people out
on their [ __ ] my mom say that word i
think i'm
learning to be more headstrong um i
think
i'm quite an emotional person that's a
really great thing but i think a part of
growing up is learning how to control
your emotions and
be stronger in your mind most things in
life it's good to have a balance um
and i think i'm getting better at that i
like to call it hibernating um
when my schedule
um is a bit more forgiving i like to
sleep lots
go for nice long walks um spend time
away from my phone
my manager always says like
especially with the pressures of work it
can sometimes feel like a wave is coming
and he just says you can choose to
either be swallowed by it or you can get
your surfboard out and
ride the wave so yeah i'm just trying to
have fun and ride the wave and not take
it so seriously i used to be someone
that didn't practice self-care so much
and sometimes you have to go through
that and then you learn you can't be
perfect all the time not to say i'm
perfect now far from it
i had a lot of fun on sex education
because
we were portraying
young people
adults a whole range of different people
experiencing the kinds of things that we
all experience in intimate situations
the highs and the lows and the different
problems filming the intimate scenes on
sex education it felt really safe we had
um some amazing intimacy coordinators
working with us i was never like a part
of the popular crew my god i was not at
all
i think you see olivia kind of trying to
be like the cool kid and doing something
risky
or something that has
consequences to them and
then she panics and you see her in her
vulnerability quite quickly and i think
that's something i relate to i think um
i was quite a little girl in high school
i think
some advice i would give to myself to
just
get to know yourself more own yourself
more um and then just find the fun with
and having confidence in yourself
i always thought everyone else was right
and i was doing something wrong and that
i had to fix something or change
something
or do something to kind of fit in or be
like everyone else and i don't think
that's the case for anyone working on
yourself and getting to know yourself
and using your voice you kind of have to
put work into that and no one else is
going to do it for you so
the iconic um
bus
scene
that whole episode just about girls
getting together and finding the joy in
supporting each other
there is a bit of a fearful connotation
um especially in
with teenage girls kind of relating to
one another and
supporting one another and not judging
each other and or being in competition
there's so much fun within it i think
yeah women are definitely supporting
each other more there's a microphone
that's being passed around now
and i just think it's important to have
an environment where women feel safe to
speak up and to not feel judged or
blamed and to just be heard in any
situation in life i think i probably
have dealt with a lot of sexism in my
life and maybe
there is a problem in the fact that i
haven't paid much attention to that i
don't really feed any energy into it and
maybe there's a problem in that maybe
there are things happening that i should
acknowledge
i think so much has changed um and
there's still lots of room for
development
but i think women just have more freedom
to be who whoever they want to be
there's not a small tiny box that we
have to fit into anymore spending so
much time on a set
around
amazing women both on bridgeton and
amongst like the other opportunities
i've had surrounding the show i've got
to meet some really incredible women
from the makeup designers on that show
to the costume designers
it was such a team of some really
incredible women if there's anything
that i can encourage to other women in
the industry or wanting to be in any
industry
um
don't be afraid to be difficult it's
such a word that we hear a lot these
days oh she's being difficult or tricky
um when actually
maybe someone's just following their
instincts and speaking out for
themselves
and i think
why not why wouldn't you don't be afraid
to be difficult
it's not a bad thing
you're just taking care of you
you